Jim we have something to talk about
right away which is two weeks ago you're
supposed to appear on the show and and
you did not at the last second I mean
literally within like I think two and a
half three hours of us taping about it
was about three hours but I couldn't
come to the show I had some issues you
had some issues and that never happens
you know no seriously you are you're a
pro no I would have covered like I could
have come and actually that leads me
into this story Alyssa I heard there was
a medical thing okay so the morning
before I was meant to be on your show
or the night before as men to be on the
show I was masturbating and when I died
I guess you yeah when I ejaculated blood
came out and I thought hey that's not
good and then we just hold on a second
you can't just launch into this is blood
shot out this is horrifying it was
Jackson Pollock painting something it
was just blood blood just shot out of
the end of my penis I remember being
concerned but I had to get up early in
the morning to do my show so I was like
I better sleep stressful sleep right but
then when you wake up in the morning you
think just you know I have to check if
this is going to happen again so I had
another way you know another wank is
that that's a hard one to get aroused
for knowing that you might have blood
coming at the end of your dick right so
I did it again
blood again Conan twice right and then
over the course of the day before I was
meant to be on show one of my testicles
swelled up into the size of a grapefruit
and I thought best that I don't do Conan
show because I couldn't walk there's
like every use like those those space
hoppers that blow up balloon that you
hold the two is when you're a kid yeah
that's how I look but I only had one
year to hold on to so you had an
inflated testicles weight is a nice
burger an infected testicle oh that and
and and so I mean to the doctors and the
doctors said that I probably had an STD
which I thought was weird because I
hadn't had sex with anyone for weeks
and so I did a few tests now over the
course of the last two weeks I've had
four doctor's fingers in my ass right
not at once individually individually
over several different days and it
turned out that I just had a prostate
infection but I thought it might be
cancer so I was very stressed out Oh see
you're fine now well no my testicle
still a little larger than should be
I've never I've never been fine you know
I mean like this whole area looks
damaged right I also with the finger I
mean it looks damaged again I I had
hemorrhoid surgery about - I'm telling
too much here but water
I had hemorrhoid surgery about a year
and a half ago and they put me I'd have
like 20 stitches up my colon so what
they did was they put me on like a
pyramid pillow like that so my ass was
in the air and they cut a sheet up and
then they put my face this is a separate
thing by the way then they put they put
my face in like a massage hole and
that's one of the times that you don't
want to be famous
right when someone's about to put
stitches in your colon and just the
anesthesia
put the mask on here as I was passing
out one of the nurses looked down at my
face when my brother's a big fan of
yours suggested that she doesn't go back
to her brother and go I was looking at
Jim Jefferies called a pretty shoddy job
yeah okay so the important thing is
you're okay now allegedly I'm what are
you taking care of your side why is this
all happening to you I'm on like three
courses of antibiotics and the testicles
going down and I have no STDs I'm like
so clean
so many antibiotics right now if you
have an STD I think I can have sex with
you and kill it this is your great line
in when you go to a bar it's a great
pickup line I can cure you you know I've
been worried about you because this is
I'm the Marie Curie of the class
you